and there's also like the fate franchise
a lot of those
fake every fate series i've watched uh
ex
i didn't watch the new ones because they
were based on i mean there's a lot of
faces
heavens fear i don't know what happened
to you i watched i love fate stay night
and fate zero are some of my favorite uh
unlimited blade works yeah some of my
favorite well that's all just the fate
no i know it is but but then you know
you want to get into fate
and you see the [ __ ] chop of like
the fate law and you're like wait
there's how many sabers
i don't want this many sabers this is
true it was just type moon being like
let's
make this universe just so difficult to
get into so you watch the anime and you
think
this is a little confusing but it makes
sense i like this and then you actually
go and look what fate is and you're like
this is a dumpster fire i feel like the
biggest
enemy against pete getting people
getting into fate
is ironically the fate fandom itself oh
no
um because okay here's the thing i'm i'm
like i don't like i have one like one of
the most popular fake videos which is
just me
parodying how how to unlike a newcomer
trying to understand the fate series
yeah yeah and like to me
good video as someone who like really
likes fate it's really not that hard to
get into
you watch unlimited blade works you
watch phase zero it doesn't matter which
one
you watch either one they're both
amazing yeah they can be enjoyed by
themselves and then
from there you just you just you just
take it from that's exactly what navi
told me when i was trying to get into
the fate
series he was like i was like okay i can
trust your opinion because you've been
with fate from the very beginning until
now
what how do i get into it and he was
just like watch fate zero
watch fake unlimited blade works and you
all understand 95 percent of the law and
the rest is just a bonus
yeah but like but like the problem is
the like collect the fake fandom as a
collective just can't seem to [ __ ]
agree on it
because there's like there's i i [ __ ]
lost lost it because there was this
reddit thread recently
on like our anime and someone had made i
think the title of the
thread was i made an easy to follow
guide on how to get into fates
right and the ultimate clickbait and
it was i i [ __ ] burst out laughing
when i saw like 800 upvotes
700 comments and i'm just like oh boy
here we [ __ ] go oh my god i'm
i'm gonna i'm gonna get the [ __ ]
popcorn and i remember like one one of
the one of the top
one of the top comments were just like
oh yeah just watch fate zero it doesn't
really [ __ ] matter face zero is good
and like the next comment is
but you're not gonna understand x if you
watch phase zero i'm just like
oh my god like how this how i
can't imagine how it looks for a
newcomer because it looks like a
[ __ ] right
yeah it does i mean i watched fate zero
first and i thought it was like a
classic right i thought it was a great
show i mean
i can re-watch faith zero yeah yeah i i
don't know i
do you get do you get put off by shows
if the fan base is toxic or [ __ ] i mean
it's
because i don't i'm just like [ __ ] you
i'm gonna watch the show make my own
opinion
yeah it's weird right because i remember
fate the fake fandom used to be a lot
more toxic
right because they used to be more toxic
oh no definitely there's there was like
there was this phase right
where if you recommended people to start
fate with fate zero
when that first came out then then there
will be people in the fake fandom who
are just like how
dare you how dare you not just recommend
the original visual novels
like it was like if you're not willing
to sit through through a hundred hour
visual novel then why are you even
enjoying this franchise you know what i
mean and now
god now it's evolved a bit now it's like
okay people just want
other people to get into fate but you
now they just don't know
how to agree on one specific way to get
into face right
and it's the problem because it's a
problem of fate being a visual novel
adaptation
because there is there is no perfect
adaptation of fate state night because
if if you think about it logically like
you if you think about something like
the monogatari series
easy you start you start with release
order all right so
you start with bakimonogate because that
came out first you know but the problem
with
fate is that chronologically the first
released
adaptation of the fate franchise is just
[ __ ]
right because it was it was a studio the
face day night yeah face day nights
adapted by studio dean right so that
that basically adapted the
the first route of the fate visual novel
the face day night vision novel right
but it's it's also like a really hard
starting point for newbies to get into
fate because it's like it's
it's just it's just [ __ ] it's just [ __ ]
you can't recommend it in this day and
age so
what you would have to recommend is
probably unlimited yeah unlimited blade
works
which is the second route but then you
know
but then people skip over the like
entire first route which is the fate
stay night route so it's it's
it's complicated because of the way the
visual novel
is laid out i i hope i genuinely thought
fate stay night
and fate stay uh unlimited blade works
was just a remake of
fate stay night yeah you'd think so
right is it not no no no
okay completely different i think from
my understanding correct me if i'm wrong
okay
fate stay night unlimited blade works
and heaven's feel are just different
endings to fate stay night yeah
okay so i feel like this is how nasa
must feel trying to [ __ ]
saying that the monogatari series is
complicated like no no it's
okay so yeah there are like three roots
in in the original face oh my god i'm
doing the [ __ ]
i'm doing the meme now this is the short
version
what happened to numbers what happened
to the numbers
it's because of the way visual novels
are laid out with different routes
right so you think of something like
clan ad or something where like a
different route you get a different girl
or like you know
that's that's like a pokemon women are
like poe
so in fate it's like every route is
completely different but it starts at
the same starting point
okay if that makes sense um so
technically in a notepad like do i need
to like write this [ __ ] they all start
at the same starting point but that's
not made apparent
in the anime adaptations no no i [ __ ]
hate it which is why
you would which is why you would think
that unlimited blade works and fate
stay night and fate zero and heaven's
feel are completely different games
yeah but in retrospect they all are the
same dude sometimes i feel like i'm the
only [ __ ] who just doesn't give a
[ __ ] about half this [ __ ] because like
everyone seems to know and then i'm
sitting there like i just want to
just click trust me it took me [ __ ]
forever to understand
one percent of the money most people
like me or like you guys because i
i don't know i feel like i'm in the
minority i've been here since the
beginning so you guys
probably don't remember that there's
been two unlimited blade works
adaptations
i did not know that wait wait both by
you photo table or no one like studio
deen did face day night then i think
they did
uh unlimited blade works movie as well
yeah yeah and then you football came
along and was like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] we're starting over at
fade zero and then
and then they were like okay [ __ ] okay
we're done phase zero
[ __ ] face day night let's go to
unlimited blade works and then
adapt heaven's field i only because i
only remember that there was two fate
stay nights
yeah and then it was the there was the
studio
night this is too much and the ufo table
was like hold my beard let's do a better
adaptation and then it was just all from
there but i didn't
i didn't know about the second unlimited
yeah and this is just the
i'm i'm making fate it looks so [ __ ]
bad now it is
and we're not even mentioning all the
[ __ ] things like
this is just the main timeline canon as
well
just watch fate zero and then if you
like it come on honestly honestly from
what i've heard
if you want to get into fate just watch
faith zero and unlimited play zero is a
great [ __ ] show and it's you could
watch it on its own you don't need to
have a college degree or a phd to
understand what the [ __ ] is going on
just watch it
if you like all the characters you know
it's [ __ ] great hey watch monogatari
it's less complicated
yes so is pokemon like what are we
recommending that
a lot of fun i mean you get into it for
the good story and then you're like man
i got into it because
i was doing a fan dub of it oh yeah
someone else's fan dub of it oh okay i
think i was playing like
how the hell are you doing abridged of
the fate series it wasn't the british
i know but like just the hypothetical
question has anyone done an approach of
this yeah no people have done in the
bridge over
there he's on the bridge of everything
yeah how do you abridge something that
complicated
i mean it's you can just abridge a
certain show but like
like having to explain the entire
franchise
i mean that's uh that's that's that's an
undertaking
i wanna i wanna fade a bridge where the
entire bridge is just them explaining
the fate law
oh no i'm actually doing a video on that
spoilers
john promoting his future content yeah
yeah yeah it's it's probably not going
to be helped by the times this
this like this episode comes out but uh
i i don't know it's
there's different because the fate the
fake franchise is so wide right but
it's like just this rabbit hole that you
can just sink in and there will always i
feel like we found a trap talking about
it here yeah yeah yeah
but but that's the thing like if if you
just want to enjoy fate zero and
unlimited blade works you can you can
just that's what i did yeah
yeah what did you think of them then i
loved them both individually i felt very
satisfied and i felt that
i'm okay not having more i'm like i was
i saw the
the you know it's like you finish it and
then you walk outside and you see the
rest of the world on fire and you're
like
no not today